extreme nothing in twilight is easy in a
series as dark and romantic as the
twilight saga it's always important for
the actors to be serious at all times
just kidding yeah
when it comes to behind the scenes and
blooper reels it's not all grimaces and
brooding stairs
where are we going
dude you can't do that i'm gonna die
let's take a look at all the funny cute
and amazingly cool outtakes from the
series that brought us one of the
world's most iconic couples
okay i'm sorry i can't look at you when
i do it alright
it's always best to start off interviews
with a laugh in this blooper robert
pattinson and kristen stewart try to get
the ball rolling with an introduction
emphasis on try
robert pattinson and i'm playing edward
cullen
they're here to let us know who they're
playing and when the film is being
released
december december apparently there's
some disagreement about how to deliver
the information
rob he's waiting for you what wait
what's going on robert's looking a bit
confused and so are we wait for what
you're lying to finish oh okay
now we all know actors have to go
through the rigorous process of learning
hundreds of lines it's hard work and
hard on the brain but even actors as
disciplined as robert have some slight
slip ups that's okay because it ends up
being on the blooper reel much to our
delight good thing he has kristen by his
side to let him know what's
happening here's jayla now oh there's
taylor everyone wants to get a word in
with taylor lautner the man responsible
for bringing the character jacob black
to life on screen who wouldn't want to
get an interview with him after all he
is one of twilight's biggest and cutest
stars looks like he's not up to
answering any questions today when you
don't respond dude
it's kind of rough man ever struggle
with your car door let's face it we've
all been there it's hard to get it open
when it has other plans for you in these
bloopers the actors can't seem to get
their props to cooperate with them who
knew it could be so hard and what are
you supposed to do when the door won't
open all you can do is laugh and play it
off for the cameras
this next entry is sure to make you
laugh is that a super speeding werewolf
no it's just taylor lautner filming one
of his many running scenes for this
particular one that they're filming he
had to run while holding kristen stewart
let's be honest everyone trips now and
again fortunately for most of us a
camera isn't rolling to watch it happen
making a silly face for the camera the
temptation is hard to resist fortunately
for taylor he looks super cute while
doing it he looks a bit nervous as he's
about to shoot an intense scene where
he's flung back against the wall luckily
for him there's something soft to catch
him you go taylor
you imprinted on my daughter another
iconic scene of the twilight saga is
when bella finds out jacob has imprinted
on her daughter who wouldn't be mad if
their baby was nicknamed
this monster she gets extremely angry
but sometimes it's hard to be angry at
your best friend especially if you're
buddies in real life okay fine but
you guys are never sleeping in the same
room looks like robert pattinson is
still forgetting his lines and his cues
not that you would know by watching the
final movie but it seems like some of
his cast members are getting a little
frustrated with robert's forgetfulness
specifically bryce dallas howard the
actress who played the antagonist
victoria
charge
turn them into dust
cool stunts fighting choreography it all
comes with the territory when you're
playing a vampire unfortunately for
robert he's a little clumsy as he tries
to execute a barrel roll move
whoops can you imagine if this kind of
clumsiness made it into the movie that
definitely would have changed the tone
of the film
nikki reed the woman behind the
character rosalie cullen is as cute as
they come even though her character is a
bit hardcore she's a sweetheart and the
only thing that could make her cuter is
by adding a baby the baby may not be
thrilled to be on set but nikki
certainly seems to be enjoying holding
him he never cries and he sleeps all
night
stumble stumble fall edward is supposed
to carry bella away in this scene like
the dashing hero he is and it should be
easy since vampires have super strength
it doesn't look like robert has that
ability though
arrow and alice are on opposing sides in
breaking dawn but michael sheen and
ashley greene are onset bffs their
interactions are priceless and there's
definitely some platonic chemistry
between them as they goof around we
can't help but wonder what they're
talking about behind the scenes maybe
it's some hot gossip
who doesn't love the honeymoon moment
where edward and bella get all cuddly by
the waterfall they hold on to each other
tenderly it's not exactly a laughing
moment but things definitely got silly
while robert and kristen try to film the
romantic scene
it's hard to keep a straight face while
running especially if you're running
backward of course elizabeth rieser who
plays as me cullen wasn't supposed to go
that way she's supposed to be running at
vampiric speeds by way of running on a
moving floor at least the floor moving
backward makes for a good clip for the
blooper reel maybe a tad slower
if you've seen breaking dawn part one
you know bella undergoes one heck of a
pregnancy i mean she was pregnant with a
half human half vampire baby throughout
breaking dawn bella is filled with pain
and agony but there's still a reason to
smile when you're being silly on set
broken along her ribs
that one
fights just like dance numbers are
strictly choreographed and that's true
for the final battle of breaking dawn
but sometimes it's hard to tell if the
actors are engaged in a fight sequence
or a tender dance
david slade was chosen to be the
director of eclipse because of his past
works in the horror genre and because of
his more grim works it definitely comes
across in the final film but it looks
like he also has a funny side when
working now sometimes directors and
other creatives butt heads and sometimes
things get a little physical don't worry
it's all in good fun see that
it's just not nice
sometimes you just have to shake loose
and let it all go with some interesting
dance moves especially when you've got
all that hair to whip around that's what
these two actors are doing after a long
rainy day of shooting
we love our job it's glamorous
we love to watch a movie with rain
soaked scenes it's very romantic and
dramatic but filming in the rain can be
kind of a pain for the actors and crew
involved what are you doing down there
just standing
in the mud
watch kristen stewart drown in the rain
and in her lines
i'm drowning i'm sorry
this isn't a disney movie but it is time
for a musical number
well maybe no singing but there is some
dancing wouldn't it be funny as we're
standing here facing off with the
volturi if we did a dance-off sometimes
the cast just needs to break out into a
dance it looks like the actors who
portrayed the cullen family and their
allies thought it would be funny to take
a west side story approach to the battle
rather than fighting with their fists
they were right
[Applause]
it's always interesting to watch an
actor break character with giggles and
smiles or see what exactly went into the
making of a film any twilight fan will
be happy to know that the actors had a
fun time creating the movie maybe almost
as much fun as we had watching the final
product
and we really hope you enjoy this clip
exclusively
we hope you've enjoyed checking out some
of the laughs and movie magic that went
into making the twilight saga what were
your favorite moments let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching
[Music]
you